welcome January we're gonna be seeing
Jennifer Lopez starring in her first TV
series and she got refreshingly candid
with our Kevin Frazier just moments
after she stepped off the set I want you
to explain what is going on with your
face right now what welcome I walk into
the white Harley
I am Harley I am a New York detective
she's just been in a little bit of a
fender bender it's not terrible but
there's a little bit of you know kind of
bruising action and stuff going on okay
well now that she is taking on producing
and starring in shades of blue Jayla
proves she is just like us
how well even the girl who can pull off
this struggles with body issues I
haven't been working out as much why
I've been doing the series so I feel a
tiny bit out of shape right now but
that's okay cuz I'm about to get into it
and I know it in my mind I'm like okay
now you're gonna start dancing like what
you hear eight nine hours a day and it's
gonna be a whole different story and
then you know we'll tighten it back up
real quick
the tighten will happen for her Vegas
show which starts January the 20th Idol
picks up two weeks before that yep
Jennifer is multitasking just like every
working mom trying to balance
commitments and kids like the kids are
coming over in a little while she and
I'm Jenner together but I don't see them
and they don't see me then it's not
happiness gonna [ __ ] me so that has I
like get up and like this morning I had
to work out and then I sit down and I
have lunch with them before I come over
here and I go you know what
since we're shooting all the way through
I'll have the kids come over at 6:30
they can bring me dinner cuz we had some
leftovers and they can bring that over
and don't you know it's just like every
day is like that all right guys quiet
laughter Kevin spent some time with JLo
on her New York set she dropped a few
tips on how to be your best self you
gotta set limits and she does it with
the paparazzi I asked him not to come to
where I live and I said I'll play with
you anywhere else in the city
but just not where I live sometimes
they're not as respectful but and
they'll get that picture in the morning
but I can't I just have to get to work
I'm an actress mode right now I get
serious act or another priority listen
closely it's sleep and here's why there
is a limit a moment you will fall down
at certain point you know
and mommies can't do that mommies have
to be good for the babies at all times
they need to know that you're solid and
strong and good so sleep is very
important I you know I get my seven to
eight hours of sleep no matter what
you're like a baby that that wait a
little bit I might be a little late here
or there we're gonna get stuff done